so him and I have just been notoriously
spineless around these in these types of
situations like we've had
servers what but oh the soup thing yeah
the soup thing like we've had like a hot
boiling soup thrown at our face and and
Bobby ended up tipping him like $200 no
he does more money what yeah like we're
very spineless but we did no like the
gorilla biscuit S no no you don't get it
dude what Happ dude dude I'll get it
this BR it this is west coast of eyes
bro that's why I hate this not East
Coast that's why I hate this place no
check it out dude think of this
mentality dude bro I'm listen will you
listen to me dude I'm listening all
right tell me I'm going to go back there
yeah I pay him 200 bucks tip yeah the
next time which it happened he'll chill
the soup before he throws it
in no he just sit it down it's
gacho so anyway wait why did they throw
soup in it he was it seemed like he a
really bad day he just just kind of TOS
the food he looked like he was having a
really bad he was angry and he just slid
it across and all the soup kind all over
Oh I thought it was like you guys got an
argument no no no he just was and then
you know he was just a bad server oh or
like if the food is good or if they've
gotten our order wrong we don't speak
up but I I I I don't know if that I
don't think that because you you're
first of all can I say something yeah I
li I lied you've never
snored oh my God we are 50 minutes in
you're full of it you're lying as a
bit what no I don't snore and he's I'm
tell thank you he likes seeing if he can
did you really lie I lied before you he
likes to show that he can rally people
for his cause no matter what and blindly
defended you [__] do you guys have
soup soup I get me a [__] thing of
shf to your Campbell you're going down
you [__] mongel kiding me what you
call me a m oh yeah it's
good dog dog yeah yeah yeah no but we
were in Seattle once in a movie theater
and we got yelled at by this couple in
front of us for um screaming Scream the
jump scenes in a horror movie The Jump
scenes we were like Bobby has a very
like shrill I do I get really scared
yeah yeah so so do I so do I yeah and so
he they turn I clutch my I
go my gay really comes down this guy was
like big mad mad that we were making
noises at all the scary parts and he
confronted us he was like if you know
that you're this type of movie Watcher
why don't you just watch the movie at
home and so that's when cuz I don't got
a [__] Red Box near me [__] what
I would have said and so Bobby that's
when we we so we the lights went on what
movie was it
hereditary the scariest [__]
movie hered who was this guy it was a
couple Patagonia wearing [__] B
Washington Wasington I'll Alpha Dog the
[__] I I tried to fight two guys at once
on a bike path in New York I just came
back from the woods I was like I'm so
Zan it's amazing they're in the bike
path and I [__] they they I was like
hey you're in a bike lane and like shut
the [__] up I dude I [__] wait why
did you say that in the [__] first
place mind your own business me yeah you
because they're in the middle of a
designated bicycle lane get run over in
the middle of the night whatever the
consequen of what whatever the
consequences they feel they [__] up
but shut your [__] mouth dude no no I
hate it I hate when
[__] you always [__] pipe up how the
[__] else are they not going to know P
Piper piping dude I got a pipe in my
pocket yeah
yeah I'm with you on this one yeah you
in the bik lane and guess what no no
it's Karen Behavior like what do you
yeah why why you [__] hack
Karen wait what else do you say e it's
whiny Behavior whiny Behavior it's whiny
baby Behavior it's whiny aristocratic
high class socialite Behavior Buffy
Behavior that's that's new that's the
one that's the one it's Buffy Behavior
dude yeah guess what yeah what's key
word of Buffy buff because I said guess
what [__] I was so nice I lead
with kindness and if you're rude back
that's what [__] snaps me and I ding
my bell I go Hey guys you're in a bike
lane just so they know because it's
really dangerous how you said it though
I swear to God I used to be full of
anger guys you're in a bike lane and by
the way nice
dicks and I popped my ass
up um but I was like Hey guys you're in
a bike lane and they go [__] [__] you
who cares and dude I like Snapped I
turned my bike around I go what the [__]
did you say he goes who cares we're in
the bike lane and and I kind of panic
sometimes I say things that are like
what like I go they go who cares or the
bike lane I go why car and so do other
bikers so then uh they were like [__]
you and dude I took my bike and by the
way I've got my stereo playing I've got
a [__] huge JBL like ghetto blaster
playing what are you playing what's the
Third Eye Blind
semi really so while this is happening
it's
like you know and dude I step on my bike
I throw it on the ground I go what the
[__] are you going to do about it right
now I go [__] apologize and he goes
all right man I'm sorry I'm sorry and I
go now you and he goes all right man I'm
sorry and I go yeah well good just be
safe because people can get hurt and
then we shook hands and when I biked
away they go thank you you were right I
was like yes Works wow it worked in that
circumstance but they were white so I
was like yeah [__] you if they were with
Brothers I would have been like your
world I'm just living in
it that's a that's an interesting
question what if there were two Asian
guys who would say it I honestly I I was
making a funny haha I would have said
hey hey bike lane to anyone